look at this beautiful Hawaiian creature
what is he doing
it's the peel back salamander over there
releasing his natural flavor into the
environment
so when peak falls dry chilling in this
jungle again though I heard that the
that the waterfall is pretty dope and
Joe told me that it heals the body the
soul so I should come out this waterfall
with a six-pack and a huge penis welcome
to another episode of fat free ducks
Hawaiian tour you thought it was over
nothing is over until I say so [ __ ] and
behind me we have a Mexican that nobody
wants so said why don't you kill
yourself avocado avocado come from trick
I thought I'm a cutter came from the
from the ground man hey why don't you
shut the hell up not everybody is
Mexican I don't know what you are stupid
you uh you know what [ __ ] you okay [ __ ]
you got the pineapple came from tree -
don't lie
don't [ __ ] lie you tried oh you that
guy ok ok it's going to be like that and
junghwa d'marie jungle mexican get dark
tonight
taquitos how many people know where
avocados come from come on well geo know
Grabbe kata-kata because I come from
Baca moly Aaron hit [ __ ] like
Merlyn hurt me
like this time yeah you'll be doing like
that yeah
like this time here come to fat free
ducks pop 14 with patrol guide over here
you have something that a lot of people
don't know which is water this is water
you can drink it if you like you will
not get sick
go ahead go into the water and drink it
trust me there's no disease in there
I've tried many times it only gives me
diarrhea that's fish even I didn't know
that I'm the best tour guide in the
world if you don't know in the jungle if
you see mushroom just eat it
everything is okay just get in the
mushroom water if if the water does not
move that mean it is safe to drink this
water is perfectly fine to drink you see
all this is vitamins look Baba food in
there that means it's okay it's like a
punch bowl that's right turtle Joe
pointed me out to a total chaos on not a
[ __ ] time it looks like a baby turtle
it was a big-ass turtle if you put a red
bag
look down here into the water you see
how it's clear and it is moving that
means you don't want to drink it it's
bad water always go for water that is
stale